He may not have the nostalgic appeal of Tobey
Maguire or the youthful energy of Tom Holland,
but Andrew Garfield still did a great job
bringing Spider-Man to life. So why were
"The Amazing Spider-Man" movies canceled after
two movies? And is the series gone for good?
When Sony made the decision to cancel Sam Raimi's
"Spider-Man 4" and move forward with a reboot,
they probably had a grand plan to keep the
franchise going for a while. About a year
after the release of the Andrew Garfield-starring
"Amazing Spider-Man" in 2012, the studio announced
an ambitious slate of follow-ups. "The Amazing
Spider-Man 2" had already been greenlit and was
well underway, but flags were also planted for
two more films to be released in 2016 and 2018.
The release of "The Amazing Spider-Man 2" in 2014
didn't meet expectations, though. It was savaged
by critics and earned significantly less than
its predecessor — which itself had already been
a steep decline from Raimi's "Spider-Man 3" in
2007. Unsure of how to right the ship, Sony's Amy
Pascal made the unprecedented decision to not only
scrap plans for the sequels, but to team up with
Marvel Studios and firmly establish Spider-Man
as part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
This resulted in a complete erasure
of the "Amazing Spider-Man" series,
halting a third installment and replacing Andrew
Garfield with Tom Holland as Spider-Man. Though
Garfield may have already been on the
outs — with rumors of his firing even
before the reboot — the series was left off
on something of a cliffhanger for audiences,
who now had to wonder if they'd ever get closure.
And prior to Garfield's return in "Spider-Man:
No Way Home," there unfortunately didn't
seem to be a way forward for a threequel.
"Whatever, I don't know, I
try not to think about it."
"How's that working out for you?"
"Perfectly."
Over the years, just about everyone involved
in "The Amazing Spider-Man" and its sequel
has been asked about a third film. Even after
Marvel Studios transported Andrew Garfield's
version of Peter Parker into the MCU, it's a
question that's been posed to much of the cast.
Sally Field wasn't thrilled by
the idea — she was apparently
uninterested in reprising her role
as Aunt May. Field admitted in 2016 —
"It's really hard to find a
three-dimensional character in it."
Dane DeHaan, who played Harry Osborn, seems
to feel differently. When asked about rumors
of his appearance in "Spider-Man: No
Way Home," the actor told Radio Times —
"I would certainly love to make
some kind of movie like that again."
As for Andrew Garfield himself, he's said he'd
happily don the spandex again — but only under
the right circumstances. In 2022, he
told the Happy Sad Confused podcast —
"I am definitely open to that. It would have
to be something very unique, very special,
and of service to the audience,
of service to the character."
In 2016, the MCU introduced a newer, younger Peter
Parker played by Tom Holland in "Captain America:
Civil War." An instant fan favorite, it seemed
that audiences had no problem saying goodbye to
Andrew Garfield and "The Amazing Spider-Man"
universe. This was further cemented by the
enormous success of "Spider-Man: Homecoming"
and "Spider-Man: Far From Home," the latter of
which was the first film for the wall-crawler
to pass a billion dollars at the box office.
But if Garfield thought he
wasn't beloved in the role,
he must've had a shock when he was asked to
make a surprise appearance in "Spider-Man:
No Way Home." Joining forces with both Tom Holland
and Tobey Maguire's versions of the webslinger,
Garfield made his triumphant return, and
the fan response was overwhelming. In fact,
multiple fan petitions popped up on Change.org
encouraging Sony to greenlight "The Amazing
Spider-Man 3" — including one that
totaled more than 30,000 signatures.
"I love you guys."
"Thank you!"
In 2022, a former Marvel lawyer spoke to Animated
Times and said that — legally speaking — there
was nothing standing in the way of Sony jumping
back into the "Amazing Spider-Man" franchise.
But while Sony hasn't commented officially on the
prospect of returning to that series of films, it
now seems like a third "Amazing Spider-Man" could
be a real possibility after years of hopelessness.
By the end of "The Amazing Spider-Man 2" Gwen
Stacy is dead, leaving Peter Parker to deal
with his grief and guilt without her. A scene
near the end of the film teased a host of new
villains — and with Dane DeHaan's Green Goblin
now knowing Spider-Man's true identity, it seemed
they were setting up some major new storylines.
Director Marc Webb told Den of Geek in 2017 —
"We were talking about the Sinister Six. Chris
Cooper was going to come back and play the [Norman
Osborn] Goblin. We were going to freeze his head,
and then he was going to be brought back to life."
Could all of that still happen? Anything
is possible — but with more than 10 years
since the film's release, it's just as likely
that something new would be dreamed up. If
it was up to Andrew Garfield, it would be
very different from Webb's initial plans.
While speaking with the Happy Sad Confused
podcast, Garfield seemed more excited about the
notion of facing off with Tom Hardy's anti-hero
Venom. Considering the multiverse shenanigans
introduced in "No Way Home," the possibilities
for a third film are practically endless.
It might be easy to assume that a third "Amazing
Spider-Man" film would simply bring back the
cast of the two previous entries, but that's not
quite as simple as it might sound. For starters,
Emma Stone probably wouldn't be back — Gwen
Stacy died at the climax of the previous movie,
after all. Plus, with more than a decade
having already passed since "The Amazing
Spider-Man 2," not everyone may
be keen to reprise their roles.
With several new entries in Sony's own corner
of the Spider-Man universe — including "Venom,"
"Morbius," and "Kraven the Hunter" — new
opportunities could present themselves.
We've already seen the villains Lizard
and Electro make a return in "No Way
Home," and they could return as either allies
or enemies as a dangerous threat emerges. There
are plenty more characters to choose from:
Tom Hardy's Venom, Michael Keaton's Vulture,
B.J. Novak's Alistair Smythe,
or even Paul Giamatti's Rhino.
"On behalf of the fine people of New
York City and real rhinos everywhere,
I ask you to put your mechanized paws in the air."
"Never!"
Another route might be for a sequel to feature an
all-new supporting cast as Spider-Man faces off
against an entirely new enemy that we've yet
to see on screen. This might be the smartest
way to go, in order to help the series separate
itself from its previous lackluster installments.
To say that the first two "Amazing Spider-Man"
films were divisive among fans and critics would
be something of an understatement. While
Andrew Garfield, Emma Stone, and the rest
of the films' casts were largely praised for
their performances, both movies were met with
criticism from reviewers for their half-baked,
overly complicated plots. Some even felt that
the creators of the films didn't even understand
the character of Spider-Man, with their grim,
dark takes on the source material not gelling
with many long-time fans of the comics.
The overwhelming fan response to
Garfield's return in "No Way Home"
proves there's a clear appetite for
more stories set in that universe,
though — and a third film would be an opportunity
for Sony to finally do it right. It would also be
their chance to prove that they can make a
great live-action "Spider-Man" film on their
own — without Sam Raimi or Marvel Studios
— the same way they did in animation with
"Into the Spider-Verse." A new story
could also fix mistakes of the past,
such as the death of Gwen Stacy or the awkward
new interpretation of the Green Goblin.
With the introduction of the multiverse,
for example, we could meet a Gwen Stacy
from another reality — maybe even a live-action
Spider-Gwen. Not only would this allow Emma Stone
to reappear against all odds, but it would
also provide a tangible way for Garfield's
version of Peter Parker to come face to face
with the grief and pain caused by her death.
During "Spider-Man: No Way Home," we
learn that the past several years have
been pretty hard on Andrew Garfield's
Peter Parker. After losing Gwen Stacy,
Peter was unable to forgive himself — and
while he tried to keep on being a friendly
neighborhood hero, he actually turned
into a much darker, angrier character.
"At some point, I just… I
stopped pulling my punches.
I got rageful."
Thankfully, the events of "No Way Home" help
Garfield's traumatized hero to heal — and
the actor believes his character will be
very different the next time we see him.
In the official art book for "No Way Home,"
Garfield elaborates a bit on this, saying —
"He's going back knowing that he
has brothers. He's going back in
re-inspired to follow his destiny, his calling
— the purpose of his life. By catching MJ,
he got to make up for a terrible tragedy
that he tried to avoid in his world."
Garfield also believes that
Peter had his eyes opened
to the mysteries of the multiverse, explaining —
"I think he's going back with a mind blown
about the cosmos and the universe and string
theory and multiple dimensionality. He's
going back incredibly reinvigorated."
If we ever get to see this version
of Peter back in his own world,
he probably won't be hitting the
bad guys quite as hard — and he
might be trying to dig deeper into the
multiverse, for better or for worse.
Considering that Marvel Studios is moving
full steam ahead on more films in their own
"Spider-Man" series starring Tom Holland, one
might wonder how they'd react to Sony embarking
on a separate journey with a wallcrawler from the
past. Back when the deal to bring Spider-Man into
the MCU was first being struck, Marvel's Kevin
Feige had no interest in continuing the series.
Sony head honcho Amy Pascal had apparently always
intended for "Amazing Spider-Man 3" to follow the
deal with Marvel Studios, just with more direct
input from them to ensure a success. It was Feige
who forced Sony's hand to reboot the franchise
rather than bring Andrew Garfield into the fold.
Today, given Marvel's success with the
multiverse — where variants of the same
character can co-exist with audiences clearly
appreciating multiple stories living side by
side — Feige and Marvel may not be as
opposed as you might think. At least,
not if you ask Holland, who clearly has no room
for jealousy. The actor told Comicbook.com —
"I would love to see 'The Amazing Spider-Man
3.' I think what was so wonderful was how
Andrew [Garfield] was able to kind of make
amends with the character and the studio,
you know, to kind of win the general public
back. [...] So should Sony decide to do that,
they would have my full support,
and obviously, so would Andrew."
"Who are you?"
"I'm Spider-Man."